[Musique]
bonsoir des enfants au que drôle d'odeur
je me demande ce que fabriquent nos deux
petits amis ça m'inquiète pas trop
le potage en vie dieu lui ça sent plutôt
bon alors que je veux tu vas voir
nicolas ses confitures m extraordinaire
là encore un peu de cidre bon train
on fait de belles confiture ya nous
aider durak n'achète pas on te lâche 2
points
[Musique]
j'ai plutôt que gelée de coings monfils
et de la gelée de panneaux et arrête de
faire le gros vilain gourmand à le tuer
peluche plutôt aux pommes aux noces
bon si on a ajouté quelques réserves
cette dure je craque
nombreux gourmands les raisins secs
seulement thèmes et madame la cuisinière
merci je dois m'occuper de famille voilà
la vanille merci et encore à ce que 2 ou
wii
le scandale a dû prendre un chef ou
voudra voir si tu recommences nounours
toquero marchand de sable c'est fini je
le ferai plus ses preuves
non les tienne moi on va arranger les
peaux maintenant qu'est ce que tu fais
nicolas rey a pas pour mais moi je suis
trop sage s'il mange de consulter le
devine icaunais oui patron on est
heureux ce soir
je viens tout de suite
[Musique]
ce sont des gens couchent isuppli borgo
c'est bien tu sais la cuisine on
arrosera demain matin mais on demandera
moment qu'elle met au côté un gros pot
de confiture pour toi oui vous êtes
toujours jute à elle ne produit pas nui
mignonne une nurse remet à demain la
nuit mais que la peau ni pas promet elle
m
[Musique]
oh
j'espère que quand votre maman fait des
confitures
vous n'êtes pas aussi gourmand que notre
gros nounours
le jupon courmont potro montre un peu ce
que tu caches derrière ton dos un vilain
gourmand allons en route
il est tard bonne nuit des enfants à
demain
[Musique]
oh